reviens en france si vous le voulez bien
sans doute avez vous vu passer cette
phrase elle et d'emmanuel macron il
s'adressait aux parlementaires de la
république en marche pour leur dire que
l'immigration c'était un sujet important
et qu'il fallait s'en saisir il a donc
promis un débat sur ce thème et il a dit
à ses troupes
nous ne devons pas être le parti des
bourgeois parce que les bourgeois il
croise pas l'immigration parce que ils
sont pas pauvres et que ce sont les
classes populaires qui sont face à ses
difficultés
voici d'abord deux points de vue avant
de lancer le débat pour savoir si la
république en marche et ou non un parti
bourgeois sûrement pas dit didier
guillaume le ministre de l'agriculture
il était hier sur public sénat et pour
lui en marche c'est le parti du peuple
ce qu'il veut c'est beaucoup d'humilité
beaucoup de sérénité
écoutez des français écouter le peuple
et se sentir proche d'eux
quand il dit hier soir aux
parlementaires d'en marche en marche ne
peut pas être un parti bourgeois en
marche doit être le parti du peuple
parce que les dongeois à eux ils n'ont
jamais aucun problème par contre le
peuple lui il a tous les problèmes voilà
dans l'imagerie populaire le bourgeoise
avant d'être celui qui n'est pas
confronté à l'immigration c'est plutôt
celui qui a de l'argent évidemment cet
argument n'avait pas échappé aux
socialistes écoutent et stéphane le foll
le maire socialiste du mans
je suis très surpris que c'est que ça
soit sur la question de l'immigration
que les manuels macron s'aperçoivent
qu'une différence entre les bourgeois et
les classes populaires parce que pour l'
isf il n'y avait pas de problème
alexandre ii avec pio emmanuel macron
c'est le président des bourgeois d'abord
c'est pas c'est pas une insulte mais
sociologiquement c'est plutôt vrai il a
été d'abord là le président est avant
tout de la nouvelle bourgeoisie urbaine
mondialisé de la start-up la chaîne des
grandes métropoles etc
on a vu que depuis les européennes il
avait conquis une partie de la
bourgeoisie plus traditionnels ses
scores dans le 16e arrondissement à
neuilly qui avait été effrayé par les
gilet jaune et ces deux villes par sa
posture d'homme d'ordre donc oui il a
réuni je dirais les deux bourgeoisie
d'une certaine manière la bourgeoisie de
gauche et la bourgeoisie de droite mais
les seuls sur l'échiquier politique qui
n'a pas d'opposition à par marine le pen
c'est se dirigent sans doute vers un
second tour un maquereau le pen et il se
dit qu'il faut qu'elle fasse le moins
possible et qu'il parle quand même aux
classes populaires alors ça c'est ce
qu'on est cynique peut-être qu il se dit
aussi que pour être président de la
république est un homme d'état
faut pas parler seulement à 25% qui
votent pour pau pour lui sa base
électorale mais également parlé au reste
du pays donc vallières est sans doute un
mélange de stratégie il faut l'espérer
aussi une prise de conscience sincère
notamment grâce au mouvement au moment
d'aider les jaunes et à la peur qui là
qu'il a véhiculé dans l'establishment et
au gouvernement qu'il ne pouvait pas
gouverner contre ou sans la majorité de
la population qui lui est malgré tout
plutôt opposées puisque sa base et lui
suffit pour gagner les élections mais
quand même assez restreint voilà il
toranian bon je vois pas bourgeois ben
bourgeois clairement je suis d'accord
que c'est pas d'ailleurs forcément une
insulte mais oui bien sûr et surtout
j'allais dire de plus en plus bourgeois
parce que ceux qui ont voté pour
lors des dernières élections c'était
clairement
voilà des français du centre droit
plutôt libéraux plutôt les
caractéristiques je viens d'évoquer
alexandre donc oui à une droitisation en
ce moment des manuels mâcon en face ça
correspond voilà il ya plus de gauche
aujourd'hui en france le peuple le
peuple de droite il est plus non plus
chez les républicains il est bien
souvent dans au sein du rassemblement
national et peuple de gauche s'il en
reste 1 il est plutôt france insoumise
ou sur ces extrêmes là donc la france se
droitise la république en marche est
clairement aujourd'hui un parti beaucoup
plus de centre droit et de droite
libérale que autre chose
donc oui lui il veut il veut aussi avoir
une posture d'homme d'état qui n'oublie
pas complètement le peuple donc la
question de l'immigration pour lui c'est
une manière déjà de rentrer en campagne
par rapport à marine le pen je suis
assez d'accord donc voilà il est alors
est ce que c'est une droitisation moi ce
qui me gêne c'est qu'on me dit ah ils
parlent immigrés d'immigration donc
droitisation je pense que la société
française aujourd'hui quand on regarde
la grande enquête qui a été fait sur les
fractures au sein des français qui
avaient lieu annuellement équipe ait été
publiée par le monde
aujourd'hui il y en a presque clairement
une majorité mais écrasante qui dit que
pour eux droite et gauche ne veut plus
rien dire en revanche ils se rejoignent
sur des préoccupations des français donc
ne plus être dans le déni de ces
questions d'immigration c'est quelque
part être en phase avec savais qu'avec
les français qu'ils soient bourgeois
d'ailleurs opa bourgeois et on sent cela
oui il épouse il épouse une réalité qui
est la réalité aujourd'hui des français
que la barre est intéressant ce retour
de une analyse sociologique parce que
marxiste
ça vous paraît pertinent pour juger de
ce qu emmanuel macron pas en fait c'est
vrai qu'il ya une forme de retour de
lutte des classes mais c'est plus du
tout les luttes des classes de la
révolution industrielle
c'est effectivement la carte
là du premier tour de l'élection
présidentielle de 2017 avec les
territoires qui sont pas tellement
d'ailleurs des territoires bourgeois
mais qui sont des directoires
effectivement intégré dans la
mondialisation et qui ont voté emmanuel
macron les métropoles
et oui la métropole mais pas seulement
parce qu'il ya aussi des endroits par
exemple si vous prenez des la région de
cognac c'est une région extrêmement
prospère vous avez des donc c'est un peu
plus compliqué que ça il ya aussi une
bonne partie de l'ouest qui a voté les
bagnoles macron mais qu'ils étaient des
régions plutôt protégé du chômage et en
os et en face on a en fait la carte des
gilet jaune c'est à dire cette espèce de
hesse qui parcourent le territoire qui
sont effectivement des régions qui ont
beaucoup voté france insoumise et
surtout ce qui était à l'époque le front
national en 2017 et qui part
effectivement du reste de la france qui
passe par le centre et qui termine par
l'homme qui termine par le sud ouest
donc ce qui est important procès pas
chez donc effectivement et ça a été
durcie par les européennes puisque
finalement les jeunes et une partie de
la gauche sont partis chez les
écologistes et donc ils m'attaquent ont
maintenant en fait à l'électorat de la
droite modérée et libérale
et puis de la gauche de la gauche
libérale et ça c'est effectivement un
électorat qu'on peut dire
majoritairement bourgeois ce que je
trouve plus intéressant c'est fait pour
elles mêmes la vraie question c'est
est-ce que c'est un parti bourgeois c
est ce que c'est un parti parce que
c'est ça le l'ambiguïté depuis le début
c'est à dire qu'en dehors de la personne
d'emmanuel mâcon normalement qu'est ce
qu'on a dans un parti on a une histoire
on a un corps de doctrine on a un réseau
d'élus est une discipline de parti
et puis une sociologie électorale est en
fait ce parti est à mal l'image de mâcon
je pense qu'il est complètement
plastique que il en fait il n'a pas de
doctrine
sa direction est extrêmement faible et
c'est normal puisque en fait le vrai
patron du parti c'est le président de la
république et les élus on voit
finalement que les élus ou les militants
il applique la technique macro et je
trouve que l' aventure villani est
extrêmement intéressante c'est à dire
qu'effectivement ils sont pas liés au
parti sont pas liés à une doctrine
ils ont ils ont une ambition une
aventure personnelle il
utilise lrm dit qu on leur aventure
personnelle et le jour où ça ne les
intéresse plus ils changent et c'est
pour ça qu'on voit des députés qui
partent massivement et en fait sur
l'électorat c'est la même chose c'est un
électorat une sociologie qui n'existe
pas qui est plastique et qui se
recompose et laventure unique d'emmanuel
vacon c'est de se dire justement que
c'est un président qui en fait est un
président sans vrai parti sans vraie
majorité sans vraie électorat mais que
le magicien arrive assembler les
morceaux du puzzle au bon moment ce
qu'il a presque réussi à faire au moment
des élections européennes et peut-être
aussi sans vraie doctrine il s'en offrir
macario on comprend le l'intérêt pour
emmanuel macron de ne pas être
uniquement de représentants des classes
favorisées
mais est-ce que l'immigration est le bon
levier pour se rapprocher du peuple
est-ce qu'on peut pas penser que sur un
thème comme celui là de toute façon il
sera jamais aussi convaincant qu'une
marine le pen pour les pour les classes
dites populaires
je crois que ce qu'a fait emmanuel
macron procédant à cette déclaration
c'est de rappeler qu' il est là pour
abolir le politique et le remplacer par
le sociologique son parti à mon avis
bourgeois c'est pas là le terme le plus
adapté est un parti de bobos bobos de
gauche bobo de droite bobos qui ont le
même style de vie qui s'opposent à
d'autres styles de vie en particulier à
celui des gilet jaune
et puis peut-être à ceux des très grands
riches mais qui ont peu de contact avec
la population
donc il confirme que cette idée à mon
avis assez folle qu'on peut gouverner un
pays qui à l'histoire qui est celle de
la france de la droite et de la gauche à
partir du centre contre les périphéries
alors une périphérie qui heureusement
est dirigée par mail en chante donc on
sait qu'elle n'a pas beaucoup d'avenir
mais l'autre en revanche qui est dirigé
par la tante et la nièce
du côté du rassemblement national à mon
avis a beaucoup plus d'avenir donc
emmanuel macron fait encore une fois une
drôle de paris un drôle de pari pardon
et il poursuit dans cette veine
sociologique que personnellement je
trouve dangereuse
alors pourra revenir aux questions
d'immigration les bobos que nous sommes
allons-y ont un point de vue modéré et
critique sur l'immigration il peut y
avoir là dessus un point d'agacement qui
met tout le monde d'accord effectivement
on pense que ça va trop loin
qui a une transformation du paysage
urbain qui a une transformation du
message culturel de ce pays qui est
cette humeur très habile de ne pas
appeler plus de manière plus accentuée
les problèmes par leurs longs et de ce
point de vue là macron joue bien une
fois de plus il est virtuose et mais il
s'appuie sur la base sociologique que
lui même il dénonce le problème est là
il ya une contradiction dans sa démarche
peut-être juste pas c'est quand même de
la triangulation aux basiques en
politique internationale je fais de
l'europe mais je fais l'ouverture à la
russie oui je fais du train mes cheveux
la médiation avec l'iran et en politique
intérieure je fais de la pma pour ma
gauche et je fais de l'immigration pour
ma droite
très franchement c'est pas très raffiné
mais c'est toujours le jeu du président
copé je ne suis pas sûr que la gauche et
le peuple sur la question de la paix m
as aussi concerné que j'entends ça ça
c'est je ne sais pas big man sam
formations bourgeoises qui sont ainsi le
pari sera gagnant mais redresser ce cas
qu'il ya dernier mais je pense est un
peu vieux monde cette façon de mettre la
pma dans la population du peuple de
gauche je suis tout à fait d'accord et
sur l'immigration il va au fond du
problème
peut-être le plus aigu de ce pays en
terme de perception
les gens perçoivent ce problème comme il
ya comme l'a dit un grand sociologue
repris par françois hollande il ya une
insécurité culturel qui s'est installée
il ya pas de doute donc quand macro
évoque ce sujet il sait que
il va d'ailleurs à pas très feutrée il
sait que c'est là le point de discorde
majeure de la société française et que
en gros où il ya beaucoup plus de
bataillon de français des lecteurs
français du côté de l'agacement du côté
de la modération
donc il veut essayer de récupérer tout
ça mais je regrette il repasse par le
discours bobos et bourgeois pour le
faire en tout cas pour vous qui me
suivait chers internautes la sphère et
entendu oui en marche est un parti
bourgeois vous êtes les trois quarts à
penser ça il est difficile de remettre
en cause le côté bourgeois dans marche
me dit brownie tôt et l'ol confirmé
électeurs de ce parti en inde ont un
intérêt qui n'est pas forcément celui
d'autres catégories de français qu'il ne
côtoie pas le jugement de l'électeur
macro nhien de base sur le gilet jaune
est assez révélateur de son
embourgeoisement hébreu nitot qui
abondent dans le sens être que là bas
vrai en marche n'a effectivement pas de
colonne vertébrale doctrinale à part
dire qu'il est centriste difficile de
dire ce qu'il représente
c'était un peu le danger aussi alexandre
ii vecchio de cette prise de position
sur l'immigration c'est que c'est
tellement fins politiques dissuadant
l'immigration c'est pas du tout l'esprit
de l'esprit de remarque donc que ça va
être que des mots donc oui mais il est
dans la position de l'extrême centre
hégémonique
il n'a pas de il n'y a pas de
concurrence sur sa gauche finalement la
seule concurrents à ce qu'il a c'est
bien le pen quelconque aux qu'il arrange
plutôt donc si la pratique est rien donc
c'est ma part des débats si ça peut être
grave pour le pays puisque si on va
effectivement vers à nouveau sur vos
tours marine le pen emmanuel macron on
peut être sûr que ce sera sur fond
d'abstention massive on pourra être sûr
que ce coup-ci marine le pen sera au
mois à 40% avec ça générera une
frustration profonde chez 60% des
électeurs donc quand on est soucieux de
la démocratie et de l'avenir de son pays
ça peut être un problème d'alimenter les
frustrations de lancer des débats comme
ça sont
faire des actes concrets mais il faut
attendre peut-être qui peut-être qu'il
va le faire c'est ont jamais je ne
désespère pas désespère pas du tour non
populiste en quelque sorte d' emmanuel
macron parce que manuel l'accord à s'il
en fait populiste qui pratiquent la
désintermédiation très largement il a su
puiser tout les les corps intermédiaires
il est très à l'aise avec le numérique
mais jusqu'ici il était dans une
idéologie pour le coup vraiment du vieux
monde européenne etc
il peut être que les gilet jaune vous le
poussez un peu court non comme françois
mitterrand avait fait à la verse le
tournant de la rigueur en 83 ans verra
ça